Hilary Clinton also made a public
appearance about 48 hours ago commented
on why she believes she lost the 2016
presidential election she said she does
take personal responsibility for the
loss but there were other factors that
she also blamed let's take a look at a
little bit of Hillary Clinton's
appearance it wasn't a perfect campaign
there is no such thing but I was on the
way to winning until the combination of
Jim Comey's letter on October 28th and
Russian WikiLeaks raised doubts in the
minds of people who were inclined to
vote for me but got scared off and the
evidence for that intervening event is I
think compelling persuasive one can
still take personal responsibility but
point to particular factors that might
have swung the election but my question
is this should it even have been so
close that 77,000 votes in three swing
states could have swung the election and
the answer is no and part of it is that
Hillary Clinton was such a hampered
candidate by her personal history part
of it is that we know that the DNC was
helping Bernie Sanders not be the
nominee and helping Hillary Clinton be
the nominee and that is something that
did not play well with many Sanders
supporters although ultimately most of
them did vote for Hillary Clinton in the
end given that it was so close I agree
with Hillary Clinton it's hard to argue
that the Comey letter didn't have an
impact that Russian hacking didn't have
an impact we're only talking about
77,000 votes in the end now is this a
compliment or a criticism of Hillary
Clinton it's neither Perseids the
reality is she taking enough personal
responsibility Pat I don't know it's
kind of like a basketball game that goes
to the score of 99 to 100 and someone
misses the shot at the buzzer I mean
everyone's going to focus on that last
shot but really what happened in the
second quarter affected the outcome just
as much that's the perfect analogy her
economic message was not a particularly
strong and compelling message neither
was donald trump's but
trick Trump's message tricked more
people Hillary Clinton didn't it was
generally speaking a campaign that felt
incredibly orchestrated to the point of
a total lack of authenticity no doubt
about it but the bottom line at the end
is uh Trump was a terrible candidate and
it is shameful that 77,000 votes could
even swing it but Hillary Clinton is not
wrong it's true and it's been
corroborated that commis letter was
perfectly timed I'm not saying
deliberately timed but it worked out
that it was perfectly timed to do the
most possible damage to Hillary Clinton
and we're only talking about 77,000
votes and this really was Hillary
Clinton's election to lose not only
because the DNC coordinated her as the
candidate but also many other factors to
this the way the electoral map was set
up that was in her favor the fact that
there was a very popular incumbent
president the fact that the economy was
in a good position this really was hers
to lose I completely agree with you but
for everybody who's responding to this
video by just insulting hillary clinton
and saying what she's saying has no
merit it's not crazy to mention that you
might have partially been influenced
negatively in your election as president
of the united states by possibly illegal
foreign interference that favored the
eventual winner i think it's perfectly
legitimate to point to that but she says
she's also taking personal
responsibility and if you if you lost to
donald trump by only 77,000 votes in
three states and of course won by
millions of votes nationally uh there's
certainly some personal responsibility
to take there it's one of those things
where she's right but it just comes off
as sour grapes you know yeah absolutely
and I that's why I get I get reacting
and saying Hillary Clinton never should
have even been in this close of a race
with Trump I get that but at the same
time I don't get the reaction of saying
the fact that she's mentioning played no
role whatsoever clearly they did and you
know if she if she had won with the
margin that president Donald Trump had
won with the margin of victory electoral
II that Barack Obama won with in 2008 or
2012 then I'd be saying you know what I
don't think James commis letter made a
difference I don't think Russian
interference made a difference but we're
talking about a very slim margin
in just three states and this is also
bracketing the entire conversation that
Hillary Clinton was not the most
electable candidate in that Democratic
pool yeah I think just given the poll
numbers months ahead Bernie Sanders
would have killed Donald Trump in the
general I think that even Jim Webb and
lincoln Chafee would have stood a better
chance I think I don't know about that
and it's not I'm trying to not go by my
visceral opinion my just an intuitive
reaction but just trying to go by the
data I I think that it's definitely fair
to say that Bernie Sanders would have
stood an absolute strong chance against
Donald Trump the way that Hillary did
again she got millions more votes and
ultimately lost by 77 thousand votes in
three states from another total
perspective but I'm not as confident as
some that say Bernie would a crush Trump
I've just not seen evidence to support
that the thing is we never really know
because if the election matchup was
Donald Trump vs. Bernie Sanders the
conversation would be entirely different
a debate without right-handers TAS ya
know that everything would be different
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show we've got a heck of a show
coming up for you today Pat